[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants j'espère que vous
avez bien manger votre soupe fait votre
toilette et que vous allez bientôt vous
coucher en ont pas trop long je vais
d'abord leur apprendre une nouvelle
chanson ma petite chaîne qui connaît une
nouvelle chanson oui une très jolie
je vais la prendre à tous mes amis au
point où les enfants
je connais une nouvelle chanson
formidable
d'accord nous reprenons le refrain en
sont un
rocco du sang allons à la guerre risette
adieu à ses petits-enfants prénom ça que
ça que dans la pousseur elle en a l'air
con ap les éléphants aller propre trop
les propros les crocodiles sur les bords
du dîner son parti n'en parlons plus
[Musique]
non pas qu ils agitaient ça que non la
poussière comme s'il était d'avancer
triomphant les animaux devant sabine
altière dans la forêt s'enfuyait tout
tremblant le gros coup de coude sur mon
ordi pour son peuple à 34 ans
l'attaquant cody sur l'air des dinos mal
en pis un éléphant pas rués sur la terre
se prépare à un combat de géants
mettrait de la cour est une rivière
le crocodile si je t'assure 8 mans en
les crocos prolé propre rôle est reconnu
gervais martel son parti n'en parlons
plus
ah c'est vrai qu'elle est formidable
cette chanson je la chante tellement
bien on ne trouvait pas ah oui c'est
vrai et alors les crocodiles ils sont
retournés dans looking up lui les
crocodiles sont retournés dans l'eau et
les petits enfants sont allés comme ils
comprennent ni granès bonne nuit
monsieur endormez vous vite la gt line
à 2
demain gros gros gros gros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons en route mon fils est lé nounours
en route
mon fidèle patron bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents allez
vite vous couchez fêtes de bourg
[Musique]